ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACT WE ARE CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
POWER QUE HAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BURNER* BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES TRIAL.
CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLY.
DAILY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA.
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PEACHTREE NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMEAU'S RAY S. LOSE THREE OF US
ROBERT REAVIS.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WAKES.
WED.
MISTER SPEAKER
A QUORUM IS
PRESENT.
AQUORUM IS PRESIDENT A SAMPLING.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHITA REVEREND
OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
WHEN THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE WAS WRITTEN?
IT WAS AN AUDACIOUS ATTEMPT TO
CREATE A MORE PERFECT UNION.
IT EXPRESSED THE HOPE TO CREATE
A LAND WHERE PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT TO LIFE LIBERTY AND
THE PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS.
WHEN THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE WAS WRITTEN?
THOMAS JEFFERSON COULD NOT HAVE
ENVISIONED THAT HIS WORDS WOULD
GIVE RISE TO THE AMERICA WE KNOW
TO DAY.
WHAT ALL OF OUR FLAWS
SHORTCOMINGS IN TRAGIC MISTAKES?
AMERICA REMAINS A BOLD
EXPERIMENT.
DEMOCRACY CONTINUES TO BE A
DARING DREAM IN PROGRESS.
AS CITIZENS AND LEADERS OF OUR
GREAT NATION.
AND STATE AND NATION LET US
CONTINUE TO KEEP THIS DREAM
ALIVE.
LET US CONTINUE TO TRY OUR VERY
BEST. TO CREATE A MORE PERFECT
UNION.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER SIX WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU ROBERT --
STUFF WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
DOCTOR CHOI.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
DOCTOR CHOI THANK YOU SPEAKER --
MEMBERS AT THIS IS US LEAVE THE
PLEDGE.
OF ALL RELIGIONS ON THE SECOND.
WEEK OF OUR SESSION AS WE BEGIN
OUR NEW YEAR.
AND HOW FITTING IT IS SO FOR ME
TO HAVE THIS HONOR --
BECAUSE OF OF KOREAN --
RESOLUTION KOREAN AMERICAN THE
AVERAGE RUSSIAN WITH THE
ADOPTING LATER AND THEN TOMORROW
IS MY BIRTHDAY SO PLEASE JOIN ME --
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TOGETHER.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF ONE ISRAEL.
ARE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY DR CHOI.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
MONDAY DECEMBER THIRD 2018% OF
THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE HOUR OF TWELVE
O'CLOCK MERIDIAN.
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS CALLED ORDER BY
E. DOTSON WILSON MISSION.
ASSEMBLY CALDERON MOVES.
AND MR BRO SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE. ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW THE
SPEAKER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BIGELOW DAVID CHIU CHOI AND WHAT
TO HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
THE SPEAKER.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ACT WE ARE
CURRY BLOOM COOLEY DAILY GIPSON%
MCCARTY O'DONNELL AND WEBER TO
SPEAK ON AND INTERMENT IN MEMORY
TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPECIAL GAS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
BOTH IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
AND IN THE GALLERY --
MEMBERS IF I COULD PLEASE HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION.
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW.
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR THE
CHAMBER FOR A VERY SPECIAL.
PRESENTATION MISTER BIGELOW
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND FELLOW
MEMBERS TODAY IS A HAPPY DAY YES
TWINGE OF SADNESS TO IT. FOR
TODAY MY FELLOW MEMBERS STANDING
WITH ME TODAY IS A MAN WHO
EMBODIES BRAVERY.
HONOR AND VALOR.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN CHIEF
CAMELOT MISTER CAN HIM WHAT.
YOU GOT TO DISTINGUISH THERE ARE.
TWO HAS SERVED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS DIRECTOR OF CAL
FIRE.
TODAY HE CLOSES THE BOOK ON THIS
DISTINGUISHED CHAPTER OF HIS
LIFE.
CHIEF SOMEWHAT HAS DEDICATED HIS
CAREER TO SELFLESSNESS.
PUTTING ITS OWN LIFE AND SAFETY
ON THE LINE FAR TOO MANY TIMES
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THE RESOURCES.
THAT CALIFORNIANS SO DEARLY
CHERRIES.
CHIEF CAMELOT FIRST BEGAN HIS
FIRE CAREER IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN AS A RESERVE FIREFIGHTER
FOR THE CONTRA COSTA FIRE
PREVENTION DISTRICT.
THAT SAME YEAR IS THE YEAR THAT
HE BEGAN HIS CAREER WITH CAL
FIRE AS A SEASONAL FIREFIGHTER.
LEARNING THE BASICS OF TRAINING.
AND THE ELEMENTS OF WHAT A TRUE
FIREFIGHTER IS GOING TO HAVE TO
FACE AS HE ENTERS THE US CAREER.
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS TENURE
CHEAP CAM WHAT SHOWED INTEGRITY
PROFESSIONALISM AND EVERY
POSITION HE HELD.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE CHEAP HIM
WHAT BECAME THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE FIRE PROTECTION PROGRAMS
OVERSEEING ALL OF THE STATEWIDE
FIRE PROTECTION OPERATIONS.
INCLUDING.
FIRE PROTECTION PREVENTION
CONSERVATION FLEET MANAGEMENT
TRAINING AND SAFETY.
AND JUST ONE YEAR LATER TO TEN
WHAT TOOK OVER.
CAL FIRE AS DIRECTOR BECOMING
THE STATE FOR FORSTER.
CHIEF HIM WHAT NAVIGATED CAL
FIRE THROUGH AN UNPRECEDENTED
DROUGHT.
AND A DEAD AND DYING TREE CRISIS.
IN OUR OVERGROWN FORESTS.
THIS IS A NEW NORMAL OF
CATASTROPHIC AND DEVASTATING
FIRES.
IN 200-012-20050 SEVEN THOUSAND
ACRES BURNED IN MY DISTRICT.
THE YEAR THAT I TOOK OFFICE.
THAT BECAME OUR THIRD LARGEST
FIRE [inaudible]
SINCE THEN.
MANY MORE HAVE REPLACED IT.
MOVING THAT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND ACRE FIRE. TO
LIKE.
EIGHT SO IT IS A NEW NORM
[inaudible]
CHIEF SOMEWHAT.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
LET ME SAY THIS.
CHEAP COMMA.
THIS DATA CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LONG AND DISTINGUISHED
CAREER YOUR OUTSTANDING CIVIC
LEADERSHIP.
AND FOR OUR DEDICATION TO
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA.
ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
WE WISH YOU THE VERY BEST IN
YOUR FUTURE.
MY FRIENDS WOULD YOU PLEASE JOIN
ME AND ALSO WELL KING WELCOMING
WITH CHEAP CANNOT.
HIS FATHER.
CAN TEN WHAT.
HIS MOTHER RHIANNA THEM WHAT.
AND HIS SON WHO IS FOLLOWING IN
HIS FOOTSTEPS FATHER'S FOOTSTEPS
MISTER NICK PENLOP WOULD YOU
PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE
.
THEIR NUMBER OF MEMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SALUTE THE CHIEF.
WE WILL DO THAT AFTER THE PHOTO
OP IN THE REAR CHAMBER
.
MEMBERS PLEASE RECORD TENSION
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER I'M
GOING TO RECOGNIZE MISTER DALLI
FROM MY FLOOR.
IN THE REAR MISTER DALI FLOOR
CHORES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I ALSO TO WOULD LIKE.
TO SAY SOME KIND REMARKS ABOUT.
THE CHIEF --
OVER THE PAST FOUR FIVE YEARS --
I'VE GOT TO KNOW HIM VERY
CLOSELY AS YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
NATURAL DISASTERS --
BEYOND WHAT WE GIVE YOU EVER
IMAGINE.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY TO CAN
NOT ONLY FOR ME BUT FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS.
THAT HAVE GOTTEN TO KNOW YOU AND
AND WORK WITH YOU THE TIME THAT
WE SPENT WITH --
YES AND FEMA.
IN THE DISTRICT --
TAKING CARE OF OUR CAN ARKAN
STATE MY CONSTITUENTS AND IN
OURS TOGETHER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN.
WELL SERVED BY YOU AND YOUR TEAM.
I JUST WANT TO SAY --
GOOD LUCK ON YOUR YOUR NEXT
VENTURE LAW MAYBE AND I HOPE TO
BE PART OF THAT.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
ASSEMBLY --
WE COULDN'T FIND A BETTER MAN TO
NOT ONLY LEADERS ON FIRE BUT
ALSO FOR STREET MOST OF YOU KNOW
THAT CAL FIRE DOES DO FOR STREET.
TO AND WORKING ALONGSIDE ME WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE
LEGISLATION THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
WORK WITH TRY TO STEAM
STREAMLINED SO THE PROCESS IS.
SO AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FRIENDSHIP
AND YOUR SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MS AGGIE ARE CURRY YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZE.
WELL CONGRATULATIONS CAN --
I CAN'T A LOT ON BEHALF OF THE
FOURTH DISTRICT WE WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE THE TIME YOU'VE
SPENT WITH ALL OF US BUT MOST OF
ALL.
I MEAN I MISS OUR FRIENDSHIP
THAT I ALWAYS KNEW THAT ALL THE
FIRES THAT I'VE HAD THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS IS THAT I KNEW I
WOULD SEE A REALLY.
A FACE THERE THAT WOULD MAKE
SURE OF MY PEOPLE WOULD BE SAY.
THAT THE FIREFIGHTERS AND
RESPOND AS WOULD BE SAFE.
AND THAT YOU ALWAYS THOUGHT OF
EVERYBODY.
AND I YOU ALWAYS MADE SURE THAT
I WAS GOING ON THE FIRES BECAUSE
THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN --
BUT AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR RETIREMENT AND YES YOU
STILL ME LOVE SOMEONE
[inaudible]
I M. AS YOU BIGELOW YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
UP IN THE GALLERY MISS MONICA
GIVE ITS.
THIS JANET THERE --
BARRETT SAN ANTONIA OF FABBRO --
THAT ARE HERE AS GUESTS.
OF MR CAM LIVE AND I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THEM
WHERE THEY WERE THE RIGHT OVER
HERE.
MEMBERS.
PETER PEOPLE A MAN I'M NOT A LOT.
IN HIS CAREER AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ALSO SAY ON A PERSONAL
NOTE FORTY FIVE YEARS AS A
FIREMAN HAVING WORKED WITH.
WITH BOTH HE MISTER CAN A LOT
AND HE MISTER KIM WHAT YOUNG
MISTER THEM WHAT.
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH THEM AND SERVE THEM AND
THEY WON'T BE GOING FAR FOR THE
BE MOVING INTO ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
FIVE FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER
[inaudible]
MS GONZALES.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ HAS GAS
IN THE GALLERY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S MY
GREAT PLEASURE TO RECOGNIZE IN
THE GALLERY FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOWARD WAYNE AND HIS
GRADUATE CLASS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAYNE
REPRESENTED THE SAN DIEGO AREA
AND ASSEMBLY FROM NINETEEN
NINETY SIX TO TWO THOUSAND TWO
HE IN A STUDENTS ARE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AS PART OF HIS COURSE
ON LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY PLEASE
JOIN ME IN GIVING HIM A WARM
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THE FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
HIS GRADUATE STUDENTS.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU
HAS A VERY SPECIAL GUEST IN THE
CHAMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES --
TODAY I RISE TO INTRODUCE A DEAR
FRIEND AND A SAN FRANCISCO
NATIVE.
NEWLY ELECTED MEMBER OF THE
STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
BILLY ECHO IN.
AIR TO HER ELECTION SHE HAS BEEN
A RISING STAR IN MY CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN IN OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
FIRST ELECTED TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
EIGHT YEARS AGO SHE SERVED TWO
CONSECUTIVE TERMS WHILE ON THE
BOARD SHE SERVED AS A
CHAIRPERSON OF OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND ENDED HER
LOCAL CAREER AS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
SHE IS SOMEONE WHO HAS
DEMONSTRATED TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP ABILITIES BUSINESS
DOCUMENT AND AN UNDERSTANDING OF
FISCAL POLICY.
THIS PAST NOVEMBER SHE WAS
ELECTED TO REPRESENT THE NEARLY
TEN MILLION TAXPAYERS IN THE
SECOND DISTRICT ON THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION WHICH COMPRISES OF
THE TWENTY THREE COUNTIES ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S COAST LINE.
FROM THE OREGON BORDER DOWN TO
SANTA BARBARA ME IN WELCOMING A
WOMAN OF WHOM I AM VERY PROUD OF
THE YOUNGEST CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICER EVER ELECTED IN
CALIFORNIA.
MY FRIEND MOLLY ECHOING
.
MEMBERS YOUR ATTENTION.
DOCTOR WOULD HAS GUEST WITH US
ON THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY
DOCTOR WHEN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE TODAY THE FROM THE
CONSULATE GENERAL OF JAPAN SAN
IN SAN FRANCISCO CONSUL GENERAL.
TOWED TO MICAH WILL YAMA.
MY JAPANESE IS A LITTLE LIKE
HERE FOLKS SO HANG WITH ME VICE
CONSUL ARE REAL.
ONO.
FROM THE CITY OF RICCO RICKLES
ISN'T TALKING.
TO THE DEPUTY MAYOR MY SUKI
OKAMOTO.
THE SPECIAL ADVISER KIYOSHI
MARKING ME.
AND WE ALSO HAVE IS WITH THIS
THE BY MAYOR OF CRESCENT CITY
BLAKE IN SCORE A CHRIS HOWARD
THE DON'T A DOLLAR COUNTY
SUPERVISOR IN CANADA CAM KEVIN
O'DONNELL ASSISTANT --
COUNCIL GENERAL FOR INTER INTER
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS THEY'RE
HERE TODAY TO CELEBRATE AND
LEARN FROM US THEY'RE WORKING
THE THE CITY OF RICO DIDN'T.
THE YEAH THANK YOU THEY SAID IT
BETTER -- I
TRIED IT REALLY DID TIED REALLY --
TO THEY THERE'S A SISTER SISTER
CITY RELATIONSHIP THAT DEVELOPED
AFTER AN EARTHQUAKE IN AND
TSUNAMI IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THAT DEVASTATED DESTROYED AT
CITY OF TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
SO CRESCENT CITY IS LEARNING
FROM THEM AND THEY HAVE MADE
SEVERAL TRIPS HERE THERE'S A
THERE'S A WONDERFUL SISTER CITY
RELATIONSHIP WE MET WITH THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
TODAY SO HOW TO SEE HOW WE CAN
BETTER.
COORDINATE AND LEARN FROM EACH
OTHER ON THE THE BUT WITH THE
IMPACTS OF THESE DEVASTATING
DISASTERS SO I HAVE A RESOLUTION
FOR THEIR SISTER CITIES AND THE
MAYOR AND THE A JOINT RIGHT A
JOINT RESOLUTION IN IS THAT THEY
WILL BE AFTER THEY LEAVE US HERE
THEY WILL BE.
VISITING THE SENATE SO.
THANK YOU VERY
.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE PRESENCE OF A FORMER MEMBER
OF THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
NOW.
CURRENTLY ON THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION THE HONORABLE TED
GAINES HAS JOINED US
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
SPEAKER RENDON.
FROM THE SPEAKER'S DESK IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER SPEAKER
RENDON THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS IT'S ALWAYS AN
HONOR TO BE PRESENTING SOMEONE.
WITH THE RESOLUTION UPON THEIR
RETIREMENT.
BUT TODAY IT IS AN ABSOLUTE MUST.
WE ALL KNOW.
AND APPRECIATE AND LOVE DAVE LOW
VERY MUCH.
DAVE STARTED HIS CAREER
ORGANIZING ONE ROOM SCHOOL
HOUSES ON THE CALIFORNIA
FRONTIER AND EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SOMETHING --
HE'S BEEN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION --
FOR QUITE FOR HOW LONG FOR QUITE
SEE HERE'S FOR EIGHT YEARS --
WAY LONGER THAN THAT THAT'S A
COMPLETE LIE --
AND WE KNOW ALL THE GREAT WORK
THAT HE'S DONE FOR THIS STATE
FOR WORKERS IN THIS STATE --
WE KNOW THAT KIDS WON'T LEARN
MUCH WITHOUT TEACHERS BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IN ORDER TO RUN
SCHOOLS YOU YOU NEED WORKERS --
AND ALL THE WORKERS THAT CSE A
CAN TO ME RIGHT NOW ABOUT.
HIS RETIREMENT WHICH IS COMING
UP IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS ON HIS
LAST DAY HE HAS MEETING
SCHEDULED --
WELL INTO THE WELL INTO THE
EVENING.
RECENTLY DAVE AND SEE SCA.
RAISED TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR WILD WILD
FIRE VICTIMS IN PARADISE --
SO DAVE'S WORK --
DATES COMMITMENT TO THIS STATE
IS IS SOMETHING THAT --
WE WE KNOW WE ARE GOING TO MISS
INSIDE OF THE BUILDING BUT WE
KNOW THAT IS A FOR ITS WILL
CONTINUE OUTSIDE THE BUILDING
THANK YOU DAVE Là FROM DONE.
THERE IS I'D LIKE TO KNOWLEDGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK ON THIS RETIREMENT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS
ABOUT THE AMAZING DAVE LOW ON
THE OCCASION OF HIS.
EMINENT RETIREMENT AND WANT TO
SAY CONGRATULATIONS ON EHALF OF
THE API CAUCUS AS WELL AS THANK
YOU.
FOR YOUR TREMENDOUS SERVICE THE
CALIFORNIA I'M ON BEHALF OF OUR
API CAUCUS IN A PACK CAUCUS
MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU.
FOR ALL YOU'VE DONE TO HELP US
GET HERE HELP US STAY HERE HELP
US THRIVE.
WHILE WE'RE HERE.
YOU BACK TO PARTNER IN A TRUE
FRIEND AND AND FOR THAT WE WANT
TO SAY TO YOU DAVE THANK YOU.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE I REMEMBER
BACK IN. TWENTY TWELVE WHEN I
WAS RUNNING TO HE SET UP WITH
YOU AND I WAS LIKE THIS IS THIS
IS THE GREAT DAY OF LOW I GOT
IMPRESSED THIS MAN.
AND DURING THAT TIME.
I I SAID ABOUT TO PRESS THEM
WITH A COUPLE OF FACTS ABOUT MY
BACKGROUND THAT I THOUGHT WOULD
HAVE RESIDENTS SO I TOLD THEM
THAT MY PARENTS WERE INVOLVED
WITH THE UNITED FARM WORKERS OF
AMERICA AND FOUGHT WHEN THE
GREATEST LABOR MOVEMENTS IN THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY WERE S. YEAH YOU ONE
THOUSAND MEMBERS WHAT IS NOW YES
I YOU ONE THOUSAND FOR OVER
FIFTY YEARS COMBINED.
AND I GOT I GOT A POKER FACE
DIDN'T DIDN'T CRACK ONE SMILE NO
REACTION SO I WENT ON TO THE
SECOND PART OF MY GAME PLAN
WHICH WAS. TO TELL HIM.
THAT I'D BE THE FIRST FILIPINO
AMERICAN STATE LEGISLATOR IN
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA IF I WON
THIS RACE AND MAYBE THAT WOULD.
IMPACT HIM BUT STILL I GOT
NOTHING I GOT A POKER FACE AND
WHEN I WALKED OUT OF THAT
MEETING I SAID.
YANKS DAVE Là HATES ME AND
FORTUNATELY THINGS CHANGE DAVE
WAS ABLE TO REALLY FIGHT FOR ME
TO HELP GET.
UP HERE INTO THE LEGISLATURE AND
AND IS SERVING HIS INCREDIBLE
BODY AND I LATER LEARNED.
TO KNOW AND TO LOVE THAT
UNMISTAKABLE UNIQUE AND SHALL WE
SAY ROBUST LAUGH --
THAT WEREN'T THAT WE'RE HEARING
NOW THAT HE'S KNOWN --
FOR IN IT IN IN THE WAY THAT HE
ENJOYS LIFE THANK YOU DAVE FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK.
FOR WORKING PEOPLE YOU'VE CHANGE
LIVES FOR THE BETTER PEOPLE YOU
HELP MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAVE
LIVING WAGES.
AND FAIR AND SAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS --
HEALTH CARE AND RETIREMENT
SECURITY ONE OF THE THINGS I
THINK IS MOST IMPORTANT IS IS
THAT REGARD THAT YOUR COLLEAGUES
HOLD YOU IN.
AS CHAIR OF THE LABOR COALITION
I THINK WHAT YOUR PEERS THINK IF
YOU IS ALWAYS A GREAT SIGN.
OF HOW IMPACT FOR YOU ARE SO I
WANT TO SAY THAT WELL WILL MISS
YOU DEARLY WE WISH YOU A FANTASY
ALL THE BEST THANK YOU FRANCIS
FOR SHARING DAY WITH US.
AND THANK YOU FOR ALL THE ADVICE
YOU'VE GIVEN US.
ALONG THE WAY ALL THE BEST ARE
YOUR NEW ADVENTURES AND YOU NEW
CHAPTERS IN LIFE DAVE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
I RISE TO STAND WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY TO RECOGNIZE
THE WORK.
AND MISSION OF DAY LOVE DAVE LOW.
DAVIS ALWAYS THE COOLEST AND
SMARTEST GUY IN THE ROOM AS
NOTED BY IS OFTEN A A STYLISH
PONYTAIL WHICH IS NOT SUPPORTING
TODAY.
BUT YOU'RE ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE
I KNOW THAT CAN STILL PULL THAT
OFF AND YOU DO IT WELL --
SCHOOL WORKERS REALLY WHAT I
CALL EDUCATORS BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE AT A SCHOOL SITE YOU ARE
AN EDUCATOR.
ACROSS THE STATE ARE INDEBTED TO
DAY FOR ADVOCATING FOR THEM AT
THE SACRAMENTO LEVEL FOR SURE.
WHEN PEOPLE THINK OF SCHOOLS
EIGHTEEN STIPULATING OF STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS BUT DAVE THE VOICE
OF THOSE NON TEACHING STAFF?
WHO I MAKE MAKE SCHOOLS FUNCTION?
SO I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
COLLEAGUES IN THANKING YOU FOR
YOUR DEDICATION SKILL AND
ADVANCEMENT OF EDUCATION WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR SURE WE WILL MISS YOUR
WIT AND DEDICATION BUT CERTAINLY
WILL MOSTLY MISS YOUR LAUGH I
LOVE YOUR LAUGH
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
WE HAVE BUSINESS BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THIS IS
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
WE ARE AB FILE ITEM [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ONE THIS IS A C. R. [inaudible]
THREE BY DR CHOI.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
AND OTHERS RELATIVES CARRYING
AMERICAN DAY.
DOCTOR CHOI ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
AND THE MEMBERS IT IS SO MY
HONOR AGAIN TO PRESENT TODAY ACR.
WHICH WILL RECOGNIZE SUCH
JANUARY.
TENTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS A
KOREAN AMERICAN DAY.
THIS IS SO TO WILL COMMEMORATE
THE ONE HUNDRED SIXTEENTH YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF A KOREAN.
IMMIGRATION TO AMERICA.
S. INTRODUCED --
IN THE PREVIOUS YEARS.
IN NINETEEN OH THREE THE FIRST.
ONE HUNDRED TOOL INDIVIDUALS TO
COME TO THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA FROM KOREA --
THEY ARRIVED IN NOT AS A PART OF
THE GROUP ABA.
IMMIGRATION TO WORK OFF ON THE
SUGAR PLANTATIONS IN HAWAII.
FROM NINETEEN OH FOUR TO
NINETEEN OH THREE APPROXIMATELY
ONE FALL SOME MORE ARRIVED IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
AT THIS TIME KOREAN AMERICANS
IMMIGRANTS.
ARE WERE WORKING AS SAW
FARMWORKERS WAGE LABORERS FOR
MINING COMPANIES SEND US SEX ON
HAND SO ON THE RIGHT RULES. FOR
MANY THAT THE WHO APPEAR THEY
PROBABLY YOU SERVED THIS COUNTRY
IN THE ARMED SERVICES AND THE
FORTY IN WORLD WAR TWO AS ARE.
MANY CONTINUE TO SERVE TODAY.
AS OF THE TWO THOUSAND TEN MORE
THAN ONE POINT.
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE LIVING IN
THE UNITED STATES SO HAVE A
KOREAN ANCESTRY.
THEY HAVE COME HERE IN PURSUIT
OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I AM ONE OF THEM.
THEY MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTION THE SITE IN MANY
FEARS INCLUDING FINANCE
TECHNOLOGY LAW MEDICINE
EDUCATION SPORTS [inaudible]
MEDIA US MILITARY AND THE
GOVERNMENT.
AND SO IT IS --
ON THIS DAY THAT THE WE
COMMEMORATE THE ARRIVAL OF THE
FIRST TO ONE HUNDRED CHIU BRIEFS
OVERSAW THAT TAKE THAT CAME TO
THE UNITED STATES.
AND THE CELEBRATE THEIR ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION.
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
WITH DATA I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS --
RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI.
MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF ACR THREE THE HONOR OF
VISITING BALL SOUTH KOREA AND
THE DEMILITARIZED ZONE LAST
NOVEMBER IS PART OF THE
LEGISLATIVE DELEGATION LED BY DR
CHOI.
AND I HAVE TO SELL YOU I WAS
TREMENDOUSLY IMPRESSED NOT ONLY
WITH THE COUNTRY BUT OF THE
WARMTH AN OPENING SPIRIT OF ITS
PEOPLE IT'S AN HONOR. TO JOIN
WITH THE KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY IN SUPPORT OF KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY I REGION I VOTE.
AND MISTER BLOOM.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO RISE TO
SUPPORT ACR THREE I REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF KOREAN AMERICANS ON
THE WESTERN EDGE OF LOS
ANGELES'S.
KOREATOWN AND I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE TAKING THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
HONOR ALL THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
THE KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
HAS MADE TO THE UNITED STATES
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE OF THE REGION THAT I
LIVE AND AND AS WELL TO
COMMEMORATE THE ANNIVERSARY AS
DOCTOR CHOICE SAID OF THE
ARRIVAL OF THE FIRST KOREAN
IMMIGRANTS ON JANUARY THIRTEENTH.
NINETEEN OH THREE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN YEARS AGO TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW MISTER
CHIU DAVID CHIU YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
THE HISTORY OF KOREAN AMERICAN.
IMMIGRANTS IN THE MAINLAND RUNS
THROUGH MY CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
THE FIRST ONE THOUSAND
IMMIGRANTS BETWEEN NINETEEN OH
FOUR AND NINETEEN OH SEVEN TO
THE MAINLAND CAME THROUGH SAN
FRANCISCO.
MY CITY WAS THE SITE WHERE THE
FIRST CREE AMERICAN POLITICAL
ORGANIZATIONS FORMED THE FIRST
KOREAN LANGUAGE PUBLICATION WAS
WRITTEN.
MY DISTRICT FOR MANY YEARS WAS
THE SOCIAL AND CULTURAL CENTER
OF THE GREEN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
UNTIL.
MORE CREAM AMERICANS MOVED TO
LOS ANGELES AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE PAST HUNDRED
SIXTEEN YEARS THIS IS A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS HAD A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON OUR SOCIETY.
ON BUSINESS ON TECHNOLOGY ON
CULTURE ON MEDIA AND GOVERNMENT
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT OF A C. R..
THREE MS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF A C. R..
THREE AS A MEMBER THAT
REPRESENTS ORANGE COUNTY NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF KOREAN AMERICANS
WHO HAVE NOT ONLY MADE NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY THEIR HOME BUT
HAVE INVESTED IN THEIR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
WHO HAVE MADE EDUCATION A LOOK
TOWARDS COMING TO FULLER TEN
BECAUSE OF OUR?
EXCELLENT SCHOOLS TROY HIGH
SCHOOL SUNNY HILLS HIGH SCHOOL
PARKS JUNIOR HIGH BUT I JUST
WANT TO NOTE --
JUST THIS WEEK AND I WAS ABLE TO
MEET WITH A SMALL GROUP OF CREE
AND AMERICANS WHO ARE REALTORS
AND NORTH ORANGE COUNTY AND FIND
OUT -- JUST
HEALTH THRIVING --
THAT THEY ARE DOING AND MAKING
SURE THEY'RE AVAILABLE TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS MAKING SURE THEY
UNDERSTAND THE AREA SO WE KNOW
THAT CREATE AMERICANS ARE NOT
ONLY CONTRIBUTING --
BUT CONTRIBUTING TO OUR ECONOMIC
SUCCESS AS FAR AS CALIFORNIA AND
I'M PROUD TO BE SOMEBODY WHO
REPRESENTS THEM.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA IS
FRIEDMAN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF BOTH
THE JEWISH CAUCUS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A C.
R..
FOR MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO ONE
OF THE LARGEST POPULATIONS OF
KOREAN AMERICANS IN THE NATION
WE HAVE FIVE SISTERS CITIES IN
KOREA AND I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF VISITING KOREA TWICE MYSELF --
LIKE MANY HAVE SPOKEN BEFORE ME
I WAS EXTREMELY IMPRESSED.
BY THE KOREAN NATION AND ITS
PEOPLE BY THE RESILIENCY THAT
THEY SHOW HAVING GONE FROM A WAR
TORN NATION ONE OF THE POOREST
NATIONS ON EARTH. TO A NATION
THAT DONATES TO OTHER NATIONS
AND A VERY VERY SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME -- AND
MOVED BY THE PEOPLE OF CARILLO
WHO ARE INCREDIBLY WARM.
WHO ARE?
SO POLITE AND KIND THAT I ALMOST
FELT ASHAMED.
OF MY MANNERS BEING FROM THE
UNITED.
AND OF COURSE I'M CONSTANTLY IN
AWE OF THE AMAZING KOREAN FOOD --
I'M ALSO VERY PROUD AND FEEL A
KINSHIP TO THE KOREAN PEOPLE AS
A WOMAN.
AS HAVING COME FROM GLENDALE AND
BEING ABLE TO HAVE BEEN A PART
OF THE GLENDALE CITY COUNCIL'S
ACTION. TO CREATE ONE OF THE
FIRST.
STATUES ON THE WEST COAST
ACTUALLY THE FIRST ACTUAL ON THE
WEST COAST TO COMMEMORATE THE
KOREAN COMFORT WOMEN.
A THIS STATUE STANDS AS A
MEMORIAL TO OUR SHARED HISTORY
HISTORY BUT ALSO TO THE FACT
THAT IN CONFLICTS IT TENDS TO BE
WOMEN CHILDREN.
WHO BEAR THE BRUNT OF THAT
CONFLICT IN WHO ARE OFTEN THE
INNOCENT VICTIMS OF WAR?
I'M VERY PROUD TO HAVE HIS TO
WITH THE KOREAN PEOPLE IN
INSTITUTING THAT STATUE.
PROUD THAT IT STANDS IN MY CITY
AND VERY PROUD TO STAND BEFORE
YOU TODAY.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF MY
COMMUNITY I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
ACR THREE THANK YOU [inaudible]
FAMOUS FRIEDMAN.
MISTER PATTERSON YOUR RECORD
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I TO RISE WITH OTHER.
COLLEAGUES --
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR ACR
THREE I DO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
JOINING DOCTOR CHOI.
AND MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
OTHERS TO TO US ALL OF SOUTH
KOREA -- IT
IT WITH THAT'S BEEN ON MY BUCKET
LIST AND WE WERE ABLE.
TO TO BE THERE AND SPEND SOME
WONDERFUL TIME MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT MY OLDEST SON BJ.
IS VIETNAMESE AND SURVIVED THE
VIETNAMESE WAR WE HAD WE ADOPTED
HIM.
WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW IS THAT HE
WAS CARED?
FOR IN VIETNAM DURING THAT
PERIOD OF TIME IN AN ORPHANAGE
THAT WAS --
SUPPORTED BY DONORS FROM ACROSS
THE WORLD THROUGH AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED WORLD VISION.
WORLD VISION HAD IT'S BEGINNING.
CARING FOR CHILDREN.
A LOT OF THE OF THE OF THE
KOREAN WAR.
AND BEGAN THEIR WITH GENEROUS
PEOPLE FROM ACROSS THE WORLD.
ARE HELPING THESE KOREAN.
CHILDREN AND AND FAMILIES IN
THIS VERY TERRIBLE TIME.
AS A RESULT SHARON AND I HAVE.
HELPED WORLD VISION OVER THE
YEARS AND GRATITUDE AND SAYING
THANK YOU FOR THEIR CARE OF OF
BJ AND WHAT WE LEARNED WAS FROM
THE BEGINNING.
OF WORLD VISION IN WAR TORN
POVERTY STRICKEN [inaudible]
THE KOREA.
IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
FROM BECOMING A NET RECEIVING.
NATION.
THEY WERE IN THAT.
DONATING NATION ONE OF THE MOST
GENEROUS.
COUNTRIES ON THE PLANET. TO TAKE
CARE KIDS TO WORLD VISION I JUST
FIND THAT PART OF THE REMARKABLE
STORY.
OF ACT THE KOREAN PEOPLE THEIR
STRUGGLE AND THEIR SUCCESS.
AND SO I TO JOIN MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES --
INSANE THANK YOU I HAVE
REPRESENTED A GOOD NUMBER OF OF
KOREANS IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
AND I JUST ENJOY SO MUCH THE
FRIENDSHIP AND THE ENCOURAGEMENT
THAT THEY HAVE MADE AND I HOPE
THAT THIS --
ACR RECIPROCATES OUR PRIDE
APPRECIATION AND KOREANS HAVE
MEANT -- TO
TO CALIFORNIA AND TO THE UNITED
STATES BLESS YOU ALL.
AND MISTER MURATSUCHI.
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF A
C. R..
THREE NOT ONLY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF COMMUNITIES
LIKE TORRANCE AND PALS FOR
EIGHTIES --
WHICH ATTRACTS MANY CURRENT
AMERICANS --
TO MY DISTRICT BECAUSE LARGELY
BECAUSE IF YOU NOTICE MANY
KOREAN AMERICANS TEND TO MIGRATE
TO THE AREAS WITH THE BEST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND SO YOU KNOW I ALWAYS TAKE
THAT AS A A A A A A GOOD SIGN
THAT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
STRONG AND DOING WELL.
WHEN KOREAN AMERICANS ARE COMING
TO OUR DISTRICT?
I ALSO --
RISE AS THE ONLY JAPANESE
AMERICAN IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE.
IN THE SPIRIT OF PEACE AND IN
THE SPIRIT OF EMPHASIZING THAT --
HERE WE ARE ALL AMERICANS AND
THAT THAT WE SHARE MORE THAN
WHAT DEVICES.
AND MR VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES.
I SUPPORT AC THREE MY FATHER IN
KOREA.
SO WHEN CAREER NEEDED THE UNITED
STATES WE WERE THERE.
I WAS IN THE VIETNAM CONFLICT.
AND WHEN AMERICA NEEDED CORREA.
THEY WERE THERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING SEIZED ON
THE RESOLUTION DOCTOR CHOI.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF FOR THE
NICE WORDS SAW WHO SPOKE --
AND THEN ALSO WHO ARE --
SAYING NICE THINGS SO IN YOUR
MIND I APPRECIATED THE OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE --
MADE THE NOW --
WOULD'VE GONE WITH US --
TO COREY --
BUT HE SUDDENLY GOT HOSPITALIZED
UP COULDN'T GO WITH US I'M SORRY --
MAYBE I NEXT TIME HE CAN SPEAK
UP ABOUT THAT EXPERIENCE SO WITH
THAT OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE AUTHORS AS AT THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS.
TELL AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WELL.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
.
THE CLERK WELL CLOSE RATHER
SEVENTY TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
DOCTOR CHOI BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS.
WITH US TODAY I AM PROUD TO
INTRODUCE OUR MEMBERS OF A
KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY WHO
HAVE JOINED US FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA AND KOREA. TO
CELEBRATE NOT THIS IMPORTANT DAY.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER WE
ARE BY.
GEN MEAN CAN DEPUTY CONSUL
GENERAL OF A SOME FRANCISCO.
WE ARE ALSO JOINED UP IN THE
GALLERY BY --
SEVERAL AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE-KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
THE VARIOUS --
KOREAN AMERICAN ORGANIZATIONS SO
INCLUDING IN AND KOREAN AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION SAN FRANCISCO KOREAN
AMERICAN FOUNDATION SOME
FRANCISCO KOREAN AMERICANS.
ARE SACRAMENTO KOREAN AMERICAN
PHONE THEY U. S. A KOREAN
AMERICAN NOT COMMUNITY CENTER OF
US SAN FRANCISCO.
ASSOCIATION OF THE REPUBLIC
COREY ARE ON ME U. S. WEST TO
CHAPTER NATIONAL UNIFICATION
ADVISORY COUNCIL OF A SOME
FRANCISCO.
THEY HAVE JOINED US TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE.
THIS A HISTORIC DAY.
MEMBERS OF PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM WITH THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER
.
WHAT A PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER?
TWO MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING.
TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
SIR PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED A
GERMAN TO MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
SO WE MAY PROCEED.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MOVIE BRIEFLY
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO SUBMIT A FILED
NOTICE FOR HR SIX LIMON.
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY.
GOING TO BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES I ASKED TODAY THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF ALREADY
STONE.
RB STONE WHO IS THE PRESIDENT
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AND THE A CONSTITUENT OF MINE.
AN I REFLECT UPON THE PROVISION
OF STAND ON THIS FOR AN HONORING
OUR BRIDGESTONE.
I REFLECT UPON FOR THE
INTERSECTION OF OUR LIVES HE IN
IRAN FOR THE ORIGINAL CITY
COUNCIL.
SO HE WAS A CHAMPION OF CITY
HOOD RANCHO CORDOVA WHEN IT WAS
A QUESTION ON EVERYONE'S MIND.
AND I KNOW THE FIRST TIME.
THE FIRST TIME OUR NAMES EVER
APPEARED IN PRINT TOGETHER.
IT WAS THE FALL OF TWO THOUSAND
TO WHEN THE CIRCLE BE ENDORSED
TNI.
ALONG WITH SOME OTHERS TO BE ON
THAT ORIGINAL CITY COUNCIL --
AND SO I HAVE A WHEN I REFLECT
UPON THE DEATH OF BOBBI STONE
AYE VIEW IS SORT OF THROUGH THE
LENS OF RANCHO CORDOVA MY
EXPERIENCE MY TIME IN PUBLIC
LIFE.
THAT HE HAS ALWAYS AS LONG AS
I'VE BEEN A REPRESENTATIVE OF
ANYONE HE HAS BEEN A CONSTITUENT
OF MINE.
AND WE LOST HIM ON NOVEMBER
TWENTY EIGHT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ARM.
HE DIED AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
FOUR HE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR IN PANAMA CITY
FLORIDA. TO MISTER LEE STONE AND
MISS THELMA DIVERTED.
HE SERVED IN THE U. S. AIR FORCE
WHICH WOULD EXPLAIN WHY WHO BE
IN RANCHO CORDOVA WAR HAD.
MAY THROUGH AIRFORCE BASE.
HE WAS TWENTY TWO YEARS.
HE SERVED OVERSEAS.
HE BECAME A MEMBER OF THE PRINCE
HALL MILITARY CONSISTORY MASONIC
LODGE NUMBER.
ONE THIRTY FOUR THE MARYLAND
HOLDING LARGE.
AND THE SHRINERS ASWAN TEMPLE
NUMBER.
ONE FIFTEEN WHEN HE LEFT THE
AIRFORCE HE WENT TO WORK FOR
METROPOLITAN LIFE.
BECAME ONE OF THEIR KEY REGIONAL
MANAGERS.
AND IN THOSE DAYS HE WAS SORT OF
A KEY MANAGER METROPOLITAN LIFE
[inaudible]
HAVING --
BROKE A RACIAL BARRIER AND BEAN
IN LEADERSHIP BEEN MET LIFE AS
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN HIGHLY
ACCOMPLISHED INDIVIDUAL.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO HE SERVED IN
THE METRO CHAMBER.
HE SERVED THE SACRA BLACK
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AND EVENTUALLY HE FOUNDED THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WORRY SERVICE YOUR
PRESIDENT.
AND WAS INSTRUMENTAL ACTUALLY IN
THE FORMATION OF THE UNITED
STATES BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
[inaudible]
AND WHEN I THINK OF OUR RE STONE
I KNOW HE HE WAS A CHAMPION.
A CHAMPION FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THE TOUCH ALL
COMMUNITIES.
SO HE ACTUALLY HAD A A HE USED
HIS COMMITTEE VOICE. TO SPEAK
OUT AGAINST REDLINING ISSUES.
PROMOTING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
JOB COURAGE FOR ALL COMMUNITIES.
AND HE WAS NOT JUST A SACRAMENTO
PHENOMENON SO HE ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED THE RITUAL CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHEN THERE WAS COMPETING
MEASURES ON THE BALLOT LATER TO
DO A CONGRESSIONAL REDISTRICTING
HE WAS IN THAT FIGHT?
TO YOU GO BACK TO NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR WHEN PROP ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN WAS ON THE BALLOT.
ARE STONE WAS INVOLVED IN THAT
FIGHT.
ANN ARBOR STONE JUMPED INTO THE
FIGHT ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROP -- TWO
OH NINE WHICH AFFECTED PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND THEIR OPPORTUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
SEOUL ARE.
DEFINITELY AN OUTSTANDING
INDIVIDUAL WHO GREW UP IN
SERVICE OF HIS COUNTRY.
ALWAYS IN SERVICE OF A LARGER
COMMUNITY SERVICE A CHAMPION FOR
OTHER PEOPLE.
AND FOR POLICY ISSUES WITH TOUCH
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
WAS AN ACTIVE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY OF RANCHO CORDOVA.
BUT TOUCHING PEOPLE IN
CONVERSATIONS AND SO MUCH HIGHER
LEVELS YOU WILL HEAR IN A MOMENT
[inaudible]
ARM.
HE LEAVES A LARGE AND LOVING
FAMILY SO THAT'S A CODE WORD FOR
HIS OWN KIDS.
HIS GRANDKIDS AND GREAT GAME
GRAND KIDS AS WELL.
OUR AND PRESENTS ALL OF THEM
WITH THIS LEGACY OF A MAN WHO
TOUCHED SO MANY LIVES.
WEARING SO MANY HATS.
AND NOT SHRINKING FOR SO MANY
ISSUES EVEN MORE RECENTLY AFTER
THE PASSAGE.
OF PROP SIXTY FOR THE
LEGALIZATION OF MARIJUANA JUMPED
IN THE CONVERSATION ON THE
EQUITY OF ACCESS TO THOSE JOBS.
FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE MIGHT OF HEADS SEEM TO HAVE
SOME HISTORIC IMPEDIMENTS
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THOSE LAWS
HAVE BEEN FORCED OVER SO MANY
YEARS.
SHOULD JUST A GREAT GREAT
CHAMPION AS I SAY THE SONORA
RISE IN HIS [inaudible]
MEMORY. TO A QUESTION A GERMAN
TODAY FOR THIS GENTLEMAN.
THAT -- I
STARTED MY PUBLIC LIFE TOGETHER
WITH THE ENDORSE IN THE SACK
WILL BE [inaudible]
AND AND THEN HE BECAME MY ONE OF
MY EARLY CONSTITUENTS TO THE END.
SO IT'S AN HONOR TO SPEAK ON HIS
BEHALF TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THINGS COOLEY.
DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AND MISTER SPEAKER AN
MEMBERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
A AS YOU'RE IN MEMORY OF MISTER
ARBOR STONE --
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS WE HAVE
WE MEMORIALIZE MISTER STONE
BECAUSE OF HIS TREMENDOUS
CONTRIBUTION TO THE BLACK
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA --
YOU READ HIS RESUME AND YOU READ
A LOT ABOUT HIS MILITARY SERVICE
IN A SERVICE TO COMMUNITY.
BUT HE WAS A SELFLESS AND
TIRELESS OF FIGHTER FOR EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY AND JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WELL AS SOON AS I BECAME A
MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE OF THE
FIRST PERSON ONE OF FIRST
PERSONS I'VE MET WAS OBVIOUS
STONE.
I HAD NO IDEA WHO HE WAS BUT HE
MADE SURE THAT EVERY MEMBER OF
THE BLACK CAUCUS KNEW WHO HE WAS.
AND UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
HIS MISSION WHICH WAS TO
BASICALLY PROMOTE BLACK
BUSINESSES AND BLACK ENTERPRISE
IN THE ENGAGEMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
AND SO I WAS HONORED TO KNOW HIM
AND TO SEE A PERSON WHO REALLY
WAS VERY PASSIONATE.
AND CONCERN IN A VERY SELFLESS
WAY AUBREY STONE NEVER PROMOTING
SOME BUSINESS THAT HE OWNS BUT
REALLY PROMOTING THE INCLUSION
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THE
BUSINESS LIFE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND HE DID IT EVERYWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA HE DID IT DID NOT
ONLY IN SACRAMENTO BUT IN SANDY
A GO HE DID IT THE WAY PACKED HE
DID IT TO VARIOUS KINDS OF
THINGS.
AND SUPPORT OF VARIOUS PIECES OF
LEGISLATION HE WAS ALWAYS THERE
IS A VOICE HIS CONFERENCES OF
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WILL WELL
ATTENDED.
AND SO HE KEPT THE CONCEPT OF
BLACK BUSINESSES ON THE MINDS OF
LEGISLATORS.
EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
WERE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
IT'S QUICK TO YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE
CALIFORNIA'S BLACK BUSINESS
VOICE WITHOUT ARBOR STONE.
BECAUSE THERE WERE VERY FEW
PEOPLE WHO CARRY THAT MESSAGE.
CONSISTENTLY AS HE DID WITHOUT
AN INTEREST IN HIS OWN PERSONAL
PROMOTION BUT REALLY IN A
PROMOTION OF BLACK BUSINESSES
ITSELF.
HE WAS A LEADER IN OUR CHAMBER
MOVEMENT HE ESTABLISHED THE
BLACK CHAMBER BUT HE WAS A
LEADER IN THAT WITH ALL OF THE
OTHER ENTITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE NEVER TRYING TO TAKE OVER
ANY PARTICULAR.
INDIVIDUAL CHAMBER WHERE THERE
WAS A SAN DIEGO BLACK CHAMBER OR
SOMEONE ELSE BUT REALLY TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE CHAMBERS
HAVE THE SUPPORT.
OF A STATEWIDE NETWORK THAT
WOULD HELP THEM TO GROW AND TO
DEVELOP.
AND SO WE'VE MISSED ARBOR STONE
AND HE WAS SO IMPORTANCE
INTERESTING OF HIS CONTACT.
AND HIS PRESENCE IN THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY IN THE
STATE COMMUNITY WAS SO IMPORTANT
HIM AND ALL OF THE OTHER
LEGISLATIVE INDIVIDUALS KNEW HIM
AND ALL THE AGENCIES KNEW HIM.
IT WAS KIND OF HILARIOUS IN THE
END BECAUSE THEY'VE WE PUT OUT
THE LYING IN STE A DAY HERE IN
THE CASH BECAUSE HE WAS FULL IN
JUST THAT.
OF IMPORTANT IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY OF COURSE WE HAD TO
LEARN VERY QUICKLY THEY DID
LEARN VERY QUICKLY THAT WE DON'T
HAVE BODIES LINE STATE WE'VE
ONLY HAD TWO OR THREE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE CAPITAL AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON AND YOU HAVE TO
BE A FORMER.
ELECTED OFFICIAL WHATEVER
WHATEVER BUT THEY JUST TO ME IT
WAS KIND OF A LAYER IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT.
BUT IT WAS ALSO AN EMPTY IN A
STATEMENT TO ME THAT THIS MAN
WAS THAT IMPORTANT TO THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY.
THAT WHEN HE DIED THEY WANTED
THE WHOLE WORLD TO RECOGNIZE HIM
TO SAY LOOK HE SAW IMPORTANT HE
IS IN THE STATE CAPITAL LYING IN
STATE AND SO WE HAD TO MAKE SURE
WE GET THE MESSAGE OUT SO THAT
WE WOULDN'T HAVE.
THRONGS OF PEOPLE COMING TO THE
CAPITAL LOOKING FARBER STONE BUT
IT REALLY IS IT IN MY MIND WAS A
STRONG TESTAMENT OF JUST HOW
POWERFUL HE WAS IN TERMS OF HIS
QUIET PRESENCE IN THE IN THE
FIELD OF BUSINESS.
AND BUSINESS ENTERPRISE WE THANK
HIS FAMILY FOR SHARING THEM WITH
US BECAUSE HE GAVE A LOT OF HIS
LIFE LOT OF HIS TIME AND A LOT
OF HIS RESOURCES.
AND PROMOTING BLACK BUSINESSES
AND SO I REQUEST THAT WE JOIN IN
MEMORY OF A STOPPER STONE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MISTER
GIBSON.
DIRECTX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE TO* BODY
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
OF AUBREY LEASE OLD --
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY --
MADE MENTION OF HIS HIS
TREMENDOUS RECORD OF PUBLIC
SERVICE AND SO I WAS GOING IS
VERY BRIEFLY JUST TOUCH ABOUT
JUST TALK ABOUT --
HARD AUBREY STONE THE MAN WHO
EVERY TIME HE SAW ME HE ALWAYS
SAID.
LITTLE BROTHER.
HOW YOU DOING?
IS EVERYTHING ALRIGHT
[inaudible]
AND I THE STORY IS WRITTEN.
THAT.
ARBOR STONE WAS A DRUM MAJOR FOR
JUSTICE.
LET THE RECORD BE WRITTEN.
BUT HE WAS THE JOHN A DRUM MAJOR
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
LET THE STORY BE WRITTEN.
THAT HE FOUGHT FOR THE LEAST OF
THESE.
AND LET THE STORY BE WRITTEN
THAT EVERY TIME HE SAW MY GIPSON.
HE CARED ENOUGH TO ASK.
LOW BROTHER HOW YOU DOING
[inaudible]
AMOS GIPSON [inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
ALL MOVED TO MISTER SPEAKER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
LET'S GO BACK TO MISTER
O'DONNELL MISTER O'DONNELL
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF LOS
ANGELES HARBOR COMMISSIONER.
DAVID AREA.
WHO HAS BEEN A FIXTURE ON THE LA
WATERFRONT AS A UNION WORKERS
LABOR LEADER AND SUPPORTER OF
MANY ORGANIZATIONS FOR MANY
YEARS?
DAVE WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL LONG SHORE AND
WAREHOUSE UNION.
HE SERVED AS A UNION OFFICER
SEVERAL TIMES INCLUDING THREE
TERMS AS LOCAL THIRTEEN AS
PRESIDENT.
AND ONE AS THE INTERNATIONAL
DAVE WAS AN EFFECTIVE NEGOTIATOR
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO ADVANCE THE
GOALS AND CAUSES THAT MATTERED
MOST TO HIS FELLOW WATERFRONT
WORKERS.
AFTER RETIRING DAY WAS APPOINTED
TO THE LOS ANGELES BOARD OF
HARBOUR COMMISSIONERS WHERE HE
NEVER LOST SIGHT OF THE PORTS
COR PURPOSES.
MOVING CARGO AND PROVIDING JOBS
ALL WHILE BALANCING THE NEEDS OF
THE GREATER COMMUNITY.
DURING HIS TENURE ON THE BOARD
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES BROKE
ALL TIME CARGO VOLUME RECORDS
WHILE REDUCING AIR EMISSIONS.
TWO GOALS DAVE WAS PARTICULARLY
FOCUSED ON HE FOUNDED THE SAN
PEDRO COMMUNITY ACTION CENTER IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX IN SUPPORT OF
SEVERAL OTHER COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS.
INCLUDING TOBEN SETTLEMENT HOUSE
HARBOR INTERFACE SHELTER IN THE
SAN PEDRO BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB.
DAVE WAS A FIGHTER FOR SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE HIS ENTIRE
LIFE.
HIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE PORT
AND HARBOUR COMMUNITY ARE BEYOND
MEASURE.%
DAVIS SURVIVE BIAS TO CHILDREN
SHAUNA JUSTIN AND FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN AND DIANE
MIDDLETON HIS FORMER WIFE WHO
REMAIN CLOSE.
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF DAVID ARIAN A FRIEND
TO MANY AND A CHAMPION FOR ALL
MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO ASKED WE
RISER DURING THE MEMORY OF DAVID
AREA.
DAVID ARIENS DEATH JUST TWO
WEEKS AGO WAS ANOTHER REMINDER
TO TO ALL OF US THAT NO PERSON
CAN BE DEFINED.
BY JUST ONE DESCRIPTION.
SO YOU CAN CALL OF IMMIGRANTS
AND HE WAS.
YOU CAN COLUMN A LABOR LEADER
AND A FIGHTER FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND HE WAS.
YOU CAN COLUMN A LEFT WING
RADICAL WHICH IS HOW HE
DESCRIBED HIMSELF AND HE
CERTAINLY WAS.
HE WAS ALL OF THAT AND WE HONOR
HIM FOR ALL OF THAT.
A FULL ACCOUNT OF HIS BATTLES IN
VICTORIES ON BEHALF OF WORKERS
ABOUT HALF OF HIS COMMUNITY
WOULD KEEP US HERE ALL DAY.
ALTHOUGH I'M FAMILIAR WITH ALL
OF THOSE SIDES OF DAVE AND I
WANT.
EVERYONE TO BE AWARE OF ALL OF
THE SIDES.
I ALSO STAND UP TODAY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AN ADDITIONAL SIDE
OF OF DAVE ARIAN.
THAT'S DAY VERY IN THE FAMILY
MAN.
THE MAN WHO WAS THE FATHER TO TO
ONE OF MY BEST FRIENDS SEAN AREA.
IF YOU KNOW SEAN IF YOU KNOW HIS
HUSBAND MIKE VON AND IF YOU KNOW
ANYBODY.
RELATED TO THAT THE THE GREAT
ARIENS OF OF SAN PEDRO --
YOU YOU SEE AND UNDERSTAND THEIR
HUNGER AND THEIR AND THEIR
THIRST FOR SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE.
DAVE ONCE GAVE ME A TOUR OF THE
OF THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES AND I
REMEMBER --
IT WASN'T JUST A TOUR OF OF
CARGO CONTAINERS AND AND OF
SHIPS IT WAS THIS INCREDIBLE AND
COGENT AND COMPREHENSIVE SORT OF
ANALYSIS OF OF INTERNATIONAL.
TRADE SHOW STARTING FROM --
FROM THE DUTCH REPUBLIC IN GOING
GOING THROUGH THE PORTUGUESE --
BUT FOR DAY THAT WAS NEVER
ABSTRACT NONE OF THIS WAS EVER
ABSTRACT WAS ABOUT.
HOW WHAT HAPPENS --
INTERNATIONALLY AND AN AFFECTS
THE LIVES OF INDIVIDUAL WORKING
WOMEN AND WORKING MEN.
AND IN A TIME OF GREAT NATIVISM
IN A TIME OF GREAT PROVINCIALISM
WHAT WAS MOST WHAT RESONATED
MOST WITH ME ABOUT DAY VERY IN.
WAS THAT HE SAW THE PLIGHT OF
THE DOCK WORKER.
IN HONG KONG AS LINKED TO THE
PLIGHT OF THE DOCK WORKER IN
SAID P. JOE HE SAW THE PLIGHT.
OF THE DOCK WORKER IN SINGAPORE
IN GERMANY LINKED TO THE PLIGHT
OF THE DOCK WORKER IN PANAMA.
FOR THE GREAT MAN.
WHO WAS DAY VERY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ADD MY VOICE TO
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY?
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
WITH THAT SADNESS I RISE TO
ADJOURN THIS AFTERNOON IN MEMORY
OF MY FATHER IN LAW AND WILL
GARCIA.
PASSED AWAY IN THIS FALL IN
SANTA ANA ORANGE COUNTY.
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY SIX BUT
ALSO WITH PRIDE I RISE TO TO
SHARE HIS STORY THE STORY A
STORY OF MAN Là GARCIA.
A MEXICAN AMERICAN IMMIGRANT T.
LIVE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
AND LIVE A GREAT LIFE HE WAS
BORN IN THE MEXICAN STATE OF
ZACATECAS.
IN A LOOKS SMALL TOWN CALLED A
TARGET AT ALL.
HE GREW UP IN POVERTY AND LOVE
TO LEARN.
HOWEVER HIS SCHOOLING WAS CUT
SHORT AT THE END OF THE SIXTH
GRADE.
HOWEVER HE HAD A PLAN BE BECAUSE
HE LOVES SCHOOL SO MUCH HE ASKED
HIS FAMILY IN THE SCHOOL.
COULD YOU GO TO SIX GRADE AGAIN
AND THEY SAID YES.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WAS NO
MIDDLE SCHOOL FOR MANUEL.
SO WE WENT TO WORK WITH HIS
FAMILY.
IN AGRICULTURAL WORLD EYES THAT
HE NEEDED MORE TO PROVIDE FOR
HIS FAMILY AND SO LIKE SO MANY.
HE HE WENT NORTH.
CAME TO CALIFORNIA IN SEARCH OF
A BETTER LIFE [inaudible]
HE HE STOPPED AT THE MEXICAN
BORDER WAITING FOR HIS NUMBER TO
BE CALLED THE AT THE PERCENT OF
PROGRESS.
WAITING FOR HIS NUMBER HE HAD NO
MONEY BUT HE HAD A DREAM AND THE
EIGHT DISCARDED FRUIT SCRAPS TO
SUSTAIN HIMSELF WAITING FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY ACROSS THE BOARD TO
COME TO WORK.
AS A FARMER OCCUR.
HE DID HE SUCCEEDED HE
EVENTUALLY SETTLED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RE WENT TO ADULT
SCHOOL TO LEARN ENGLISH TO
BECOME A BETTER CALIFORNIAN.
AND HE WAS A RAPID LEARNER.
WITHIN.
MONTHS HE LEARNED HOW TO READ
THE LOCAL NEWSPAPER AND WAS A
THIRTY YEAR PLUS THIS SUBSCRIBER
TO THE OC REGISTER.
HE FOUND THAT GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
LIFE IN CONSTRUCTION BECAME A
LABOR AND A FIFTY YEAR MEMBER OF
LABOR'S LOCAL.
SIX FIFTY TWO WHEN THE ONLY A
HANDFUL THE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
ACTIVE FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS.
THIS MIDDLE CLASS JOB ANNEALED
ENABLED HIM TO BUY A HOME IN
SANTA ANA.
WHERE HE MET HIS WIFE AND ALL
THE GARCIA?
HAD A FAMILY.
AND HELPED OTHERS AS WELL.
IT'S ONE OF THE GREAT --
TESTAMENTS FOR MANUEL GARCIA IS
HE REMEMBERED WHERE HE CAME FOR
REMEMBER HIS FAMILY SO OVER THE
NEXT TWO DECADES.
DOZENS OF GARCIA AND FAMILY
MEMBERS CAME AND LIVED IN HIS
HOUSE IN THE BACK OF THE HOUSE
AND THE GARAGE AS THEY TRIED TO
GET THE CALIFORNIA DREAM BECAUSE
HE SUCCEEDED.
ANYONE IN HIS FAMILY TO HAVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY AS HE DID.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST ENDURING.
AND EVERLASTING MEMORIES FOR HIS
EXTENDED FAMILY.
HE LOVES SPORTS AT THAT TIME HE
LED THE DODGERS BECAUSE THE
FERNANDO MANIA.
THAT BECAME HIS PASSION.
HE COACHED THE LOCAL LITTLE
LEAGUE TEAMS.
AND BECAME SOMEBODY NOT JUST
COACH THE TEAM BUT LOOKED AFTER
NEIGHBORHOOD KIDS WHO NEEDED
SOME EXTRA GUIDANCE.
HE SUPPORT IS LOCAL TOWN IN
COLORADO WITH THE LOCAL CLUB
THERE HELPING RAISE MONEY. TO
SEND HOME TO THE VILLAGE WHO
NEEDED SO MUCH HELP.
HE WAS ALWAYS INTRIGUED ABOUT
NATIONAL STATE AND LOCAL
POLITICS.
THE BECAUSE OF HIS EDUCATION
NEVER HAD THE AND UNFORTUNATELY
HE DIDN'T BECOME A CITIZEN FOR
THE FIRST THREE DECADES OF HIS
TIME HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT ALL CHANGED LIKE SO MANY OF
NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN HE SAW
THE ATTACKS ON IMMIGRANTS.
ON IMMIGRANTS THAT LOOK LIKE HIM.
HE SAID NO MORE [inaudible]
STOOD UP.
TOOK THE CLASSES BECAME A
CITIZEN I WAS PROUD TO CAST HIS
FIRST VOTE IN THE TWO THOUSAND
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS.
AND WAS SUPER EXCITED NOT ONLY
VOTE TO BECOME AN ACTIVE --
VOTER ENGAGED CITIZEN LATER
MEETING HAS LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVES THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIEU QUREIA.
THEN LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR CRUZ
BUSTAMANTE LOVE TALKING ABOUT
POLITICS WITH THEM.
HE WAS SUPER PROUD SEE IS
DAUGHTER.
THE TO SEE A RUN FOR SCHOOL
BOARD.
THIS PAST FALL [inaudible]
SHE WON DAYS AFTER HE PASSED
AWAY.
AGAIN WALL GONE HE LIVES A GREAT
LIFE ONE THAT NEARS THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM HERE IN OUR
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HE LEAVES BEHIND A TREMENDOUS
LEGACY.
AND IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS BRING ALL THE
GARCIA. NINE CHILDREN THIRTEEN
GRANDCHILDREN INCLUDING MY KIDS
VICTORIA AND BARBARA.
AND WITH US TODAY ARE TWO OF HIS
CHILDREN BUT DC --
AND HER BROTHER DAVID THANK YOU
LAST WEEK DURING HIS MEMORY.
AND MR DAILY OR ALSO RECOGNIZED
ON THE SAM THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IT'S AN HONOR TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER MCCARTY.
WITH THIS ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
MANUAL GARCIA WAS A RESIDENT OF
THE SIXTY NINTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS.
AS A MEMBER THE SANTA ANA ACTORS
CLUB OF THE JOOST THEATER
DOWNTOWN SANTA ANNA HE HELP
BRING SPANISH SPEAKING
PERFORMANCES TO THE GROWING
LATINO COMMUNITY IN THAT CITY.
AS WAS MENTIONED HE WAS A LONG
TIME MEMBER OF LOCAL SIX FIFTY
TWO OF THE INTERNATIONAL.
THE LABORS INTERNATIONAL UNION.
WHILE HE WAS A WORKING MEMBER.
HE WORKED ON A NUMBER OF
SIGNIFICANT CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS INCLUDING EXPANSIONS TO
THE INTERSTATE FIVE FREEWAY.
IN THE INDIANA JONES RIDE AT
DISNEYLAND.
IN HIS RETIREMENT YEARS HE
WORKED PART TIME AS A JANITOR AT
ANGEL STADIUM ENABLING HIM TO
ENJOY MANY PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL
GAMES IN THE PROCESS I THINK
THAT'S WHY HE WORKS THERE.
WAS THE GAMES MORE THAN THE
MONEY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN OFFERING
SINCERE CONDOLENCES TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY. TO LATISSE YEAR
AND TO YOUR FAMILY
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE AGAIN
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
MISS AGUILAR CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENT
IN MEMORY.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO A
JURY IN MEMORY AND TO HONOR.
NATALIE CORONA THE TWENTY TWO
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER MERCED AND THE
B. CORONA OF OUR VOCAL
CALIFORNIA.
AND A BRIGHTLY SHINING LIGHT TO
EVERYONE SHE MET.
NATALIE WAS SHOT AND KILLED ON
THE EVENING OF JANUARY TENTH.
WHILE PERFORMING HER DUTIES AS A
ROOKIE DAVIS POLICE OFFICER.
AT A ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP WHEN
SHE WAS VICTIM OF AN ACT OF
UNSPEAKABLE VIOLENCE.
NATALIE IN OUR FAMILY ARE THE
EMBODIMENT OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
HER FATHER HAVING COME TO
CALIFORNIA FROM MEXICO TO WORK
THE FIELDS WITH HIS FAMILY
COLUSA COUNTY.
WE'RE SAID WAS A TWENTY SIX
ROLLED COLUSA IT.
COLUSA COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFF AND
AFTER HE RETIRED HE RAN FOR AND
WON A SEAT ON THE COLUSA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
NOW THE SHAWMUT LIKE HER MOTHER.
IT WAS CALLED TO SERVE LIKE A
FATHER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SHE HAD TO PAY JOBS SO SHE COULD
AFFORD SCHOOL.
AND A THIRD JOB AS A VOLUNTEER.
COMMUNITY SERVICE OFFICER FOR
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT IN DAVIS.
OUR COMMITMENT TO SERVICE IS
ONLY EXCUSE EXCEEDED BY THE LOVE
FOR HER BIG COLUSA FAMILY.
INCLUDING HER SISTERS JACQUI
KATHY IN CINDY.
CHOOSE A FOUR POINT NO STUDENT.
A HOMECOMING QUEEN.
A BASKETBALL AND VOLLEYBALL
PLAYER.
AND MY FAVORITE A BOXER.
NOW HE GRADUATED FROM THE
SACRAMENTO POLICE ACADEMY JUST
MONTHS AGO IN JULY.
AND WAS RECENTLY GIVEN HER
OFFICERS BAD BY HER FATHER UPON
JOINING THE FORCE.
WE ARE ALL ALL TERRIBLY SHAKEN
BY THIS TERRIBLE LOSS.
EVERY PERSON I'VE SPOKEN WITH
THE PAST FEW DAYS A SAID NOW
ONLY IT WAS MEANT FOR GREAT
THINGS.
AND LET ME TELL YOU IF YOU LOOK
AT FACEBOOK AND HER COMMUNITY
SHE WAS.
A DARLING FOR THAT COMMUNITY.
WHEN RECALL YOU SAID THAT THIS
ROOKIE WOULD HAVE BEEN THE CHIEF?
OF POLICE IN DAVIS ONE DAY.
TODAY I RISE TO FOCUS ON THIS
WONDERFUL WOMAN.
WHOSE LIFE WAS STONE IN THE LINE
OF DUTY.
TRYING TO KEEP OTHER SAFE.
GOD BLESS HER.
GOD BLESS YOUR PARENTS THEY
RAISED A YOUNG LADY.
WHO IS A LEADER WOULD HAVE BEEN
A LEADER?
SHE TOOK LAW ENFORCEMENT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
SO MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS THAT IS NOT FORGET
NATALIE.
AND HER FAMILY IN THESE
FOLLOWING DAYS IT'LL BE VERY
DIFFICULT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN THE LINE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS ONE OF THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN THE HISTORY
OF LOS ANGELES AND VENTURA
COUNTY BEGAN TO SHORT MONTHS AGO
ON NOVEMBER EIGHTH AFTER
IGNITING AND WILL THE CANYON.
IN THE SANTA SUZANNA MOUNTAINS.
THE FIRE RAVAGED FOR NEARLY TWO
WEEKS.
AND THE STORY WAS SADLY FAMILIAR
DRY CONDITIONS ENORMOUS AMOUNTS
OF UNDERGROWTH AND FUEL.
AN ABNORMALLY HIGH WINDS.
PLAYED A ROLE.
SADLY NEARLY ALL THESE FIRES
HAVE ANOTHER THING IN COMMON
THEY OCCURRED IN OR NEAR
EXTREMELY VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
RESIDENTS HAD LITTLE TIME TO
REACT AND HAD FEW ESCAPE ROUTES.
THE FIRE RESULTED IN FATALITIES
GREAT PROPERTY LOSS.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE.
AND OF COURSE THE WILL THE FAR
WE NOW KNOW WAS NO DIFFERENT
WITHIN TWENTY MINUTES OF THE
REPORTED FIRE.
THE SANTA ANA WINDS THAT IT
REACHED FIFTY TO SIXTY MILES PER
HOUR HAD CAUSED THE FIRE TO
SPREAD SO RAPIDLY AND
PREDICTABLY.
THAT IT WAS BE FIREFIGHTING
CAPABILITIES WITHIN TWO DAYS OF
IGNITING THE FIRE HAD ENGULFED
MORE THAN SEVENTY THOUSAND ACRES
AND FORCED THE EVACUATION OF TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
FROM THE CITIES OF MALIBU IN
AGORA HILLS AND COMMUNITIES LIKE
BELL CANYON MALIBU LAKE AND OAK
PARK.
WHEN THE FIRE WAS FINALLY
CONTAINED AT SIX ELEVEN PM ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY FIRST NEARLY
NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND ACRES HAVE
BURNED ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE BUILDINGS WERE
DESTROYED?
AND HUNDREDS OF HOMES WERE GONE
THREE FIREFIGHTERS AND TWO
CIVILIANS WERE INJURED AND THREE
CIVILIANS WERE KILLED.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
FIRST RESPONDERS WHO PROTECTED
US AND THE MANY OTHERS WHO STEP
FORWARD DURING AND IN THE
AFTERMATH.
AND EVEN TODAY AS MUD COURSES.
THROUGH THE BURN AREAS WITH --
THE CURRENT RAINSTORMS.
BUT JUST LIKE ALL THE OTHER
COMMUNITIES THE FIRE WILL LEAVE
A LIFELONG SCAR ON THE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE.
WHO LOST A PART OF THEIR LIVES
AND OTHERS LOST A PART OF THEIR
COMMUNITY?
TODAY IS ONE OF THE STOPS ON A
RECOVERY AND I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF THE THREE VICTIMS OF
THE WALLS THE FIRE.
OFFERED TO CUTIS SEVENTY THREE
YEARS OLD AND A RESIDENT OF
AGORA HILLS.
WAS KNOWN AS DR DE A MISTER
DICKEY A DOCTOR TO CUTEST WAS
EIGHT RETIRED ONCOLOGIST A WORLD
TRAVELER.
AND A BRILLIANT MIND BY ALL ALL
WHO KNEW HIM.
HE LIVED IN A GORE HILLS FOR
THIRTY YEARS AND LOVED
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE CITY
ACCORDING TO HIS NEPHEW VINCENT.
SHU ZHAN BACK LION.
WAS EIGHTY THREE YEARS OLD.
AND THE MOTHER OF ANTHONY NEW
BARBARA CLIENT IN A RESIDENT OF
MALIBU.
AND ANTHONY NEW BARBARA CLIENT.
FIFTY SEVEN YEARS OLD.
ALSO A LOCAL RESIDENT WHO IS A
HUSBAND AND FATHER OF TWO
CHILDREN.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
SOLEMN MEMORY.
OF THESE VICTIMS OF THE WALLS
THE FIRE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM THE CLERK
WILL NOW READ THE NAMES.
OF THE VICTIMS OF THE WALLS THE
FIRE.
SHE SHAUN PARK LAND.
ANTHONY NEW ARE BACH LAN
[inaudible]
ALFRED JUDAS.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE STAND
AND JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
SILENCE FOR THESE VICTIMS
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
TODAY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER YEARS BIRTHDAY.
PLEASE.
HANNAH HAVE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT CAKE WILL BE
SERVED IN HIS OFFICE WHICH IS
ROOM TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN UPON
ADJOURNMENT.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY MR JONES SAWYER
THERE ALSO BE A RECEPTION TO
HONOR DAVE LOW.
AND HIS RETIREMENT IN THE WILLIE
BROWN CONFERENCE ROOM ALSO UPON
ADJOURNMENT THE SESSIONS
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY JANUARY FIFTEENTH CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY JANUARY
SIXTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY JANUARY SEVENTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION AND FRIDAY.
JANUARY EIGHTEENTH FLOOR SESSION
IS AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SEEING AND HEARING A FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES THIS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY.
JANUARY EIGHTEENTH AT NINE AM IN
THE QUORUM CALLS LIFTED